[Music]
in our previous video we defined several
terms related to spherical mirrors what
a spherical mirrors mirrors in which the
curved reflecting surface forms a part
of a sphere are called spherical mirrors
spherical mirrors can be of two types
one in which reflecting surface is
curved inwards they called concave
mirrors and the others in which the
reflecting surface is curved outwards
that called convex mirrors the center of
the reflecting surface is called the
pole the center of a sphere of which the
former part is called the centre of
curvature and the radius of that sphere
is called the radius of curvature CP
here is the radius of curvature
note that for a concave mirror the
center of curvature lies at the front of
the reflecting surface whereas for a
convex mirror it lies at the back of the
reflecting surface okay I also told you
that the midpoint of CP is called the
focal point of the respective mirror the
other name for it is principal focus
it's called so because it lies on the
principal axis okay
let's just remove the convex mirror for
a while and concentrate on the concave
mirror for now now this focal point of a
concave mirror is a little more than
just a midpoint it's also a point where
all the rays of light parallel to each
other as well as to the principal axis
converge after reflection let's try to
understand the statement in detail let's
take the Sun as our object why because I
want only parallel rays of light to be
incident on the mirror and the rays of
light from the Sun can be considered to
be almost parallel but why being a
sphere Sun emits light radially outwards
that is rays of light travel outwards
along the radius but we know that the
Sun is at a very large distance away
from the earth hence the rays from the
Sun coming towards the sir
of the earth a concert parallel so our
object which is the Sun is present at
infinity and it's emitting parallel rays
of light we know that all the rays of
light after being incident on any
surface will follow laws of reflection
we see that after reflection each ray is
indeed following those laws angle of
incidence is equal to the angle of
reflection and all the three lie in the
same plane
where are they going after reflection
well they are all meeting each other at
the principle focus yes they are all
converging at the principle focus and
this is where the image of an object is
formed yes this is an image of the Sun
and it's a real image now if you project
this point of convergence on a piece of
paper the paper at that point will start
getting hotter and will eventually catch
fire as the bulk of rays from the Sun
are all concentrated at one single point
by this concave mirror the temperature
at this point Rises and it's too much
temperature for a thin piece of paper to
withhold similarly instead of a Sun we
can take any other object kept at
infinity and the rays of light from that
object incident on the mirror will be
parallel to each other so we saw that if
the rays of light are parallel to each
other as well as to the principal axis
they will always converge at the
principal focus and this is true for any
other object as well now I would want to
mention one thing here that this does
not depend on the position of the object
yes it does not only work when the
object is at infinity no matter where
the object is kept on the principal axis
if the rays of light incident on the
mirror are parallel to each other as
well as to the principal axis
they will always converge at the
principal focus what of the rays of
light are parallel to each other but not
parallel to the principal axis where
will they go in that case let's find out
what happens then suppose that the rays
of light
are incident on the mirror as you can
see these rays are parallel to each
other but not to the principal axis
these rays will be reflected in such a
way such that the laws of reflection are
obeyed you see that here also all the
rays are converging but here the point
of convergence is not the principal
focus instead it's a point above the
principal axis this point is called
focus as all the Rays are focused at
this point it's not called the principal
focus because it does not lie on the
principal axis so we define focus as a
point where all the parallel rays
converge after bouncing off from the
reflecting surface of the concave mirror
it is the principal focus if it lies on
the principal axis and it will only lie
on the principal axis if the rays of
light are parallel to each other as well
as to the principal axis what if the
light rays are passing through the
principal focus yes it means the light
rays won't be parallel consider one
light ray from a point on the object
passing through the principal focus and
it's incident on the mirror we know that
this ray will be reflected according to
the loss of reflection consider two more
rays from different points of the object
both passing through the principal focus
incident on the mirror after reflection
from the concave mirror we see that they
all travel parallel to the first
reflected ray so what can we conclude
from this
if the rays of light passed through the
principal focus and are incident on the
mirror then after reflection they travel
parallel to each other and this is true
for any position behind the principal
focus but what if the object is kept at
the principal focus well in that case
also all the Rays will travel parallel
to each other after reflection I want to
discuss one important point before I end
this video in reality every object emits
rays of light in all possible directions
or to be more specific from
any point on an object infinitely many
rays of light travel in all the possible
directions but then where will the image
of the object be formed is it formed on
the principle focus again in the coming
videos we will learn the characteristics
of images formed by concave mirrors
[Music]